joining us now is Senator David Perdue a
Republican from Georgia senator Perdue
shares president Trump's goal of getting
rid of the diversity immigrant visa
program and has introduced legislation
to do just that senator good to see you
thanks for coming on the program tonight
I have a hard time after a hideous event
such as what we saw last night seeing
that and then seeing people come out
today who still can't connect the dots I
called it willful blindness but it's
more than that really this is a
dangerous dereliction of duty on the
part of politicians to keep this scam of
a diversity visa program going
this president called this out last year
and I give him high marks at this year
he's backing our raise act at Tom cotton
and I are putting forward and he talked
about it today we want to go to a
merit-based immigration system let's
talk about this diversity lottery
situation this is a big fraud it's it's
fraught with fraud itself it has Social
Security fraud has identity fraud but
worse than that Laura is that 30% of the
visas given out under this system go to
countries that are identified by ice as
harboring and promoting terrorism in
fact the largest recipient country for
these visas is the third largest is Iran
this is an insidious program it needs to
go away tonight who are the big
champions of this program well the left
they want diversity but what it does is
business wants us to the guest worker no
no no this is all about a program that
was envisioned by Ted Kennedy and
Schumer years ago and Bush George HW
Bush signed it into law in 1990 he did I
see there's a there's a line or a Venn
diagram maybe it's it's the the
politicians on the right and the left
who are more kind of globalist types who
they they love all these international
trade deals regardless of their effect
on the workers they love the idea of
amnesty or massive amounts of guest
workers coming into the country so
globalism and their quest for diversity
Trump's safety security workers rights
in the United States and I find that
also to be troubling well most of the
in the world have already moved to
protect their national borders their
national security and to provide for the
economic growth and they do that within
the immigration system Canada and
Australia decades ago Japan but they
went to a merit-based system where they
bring the right kind of people in today
relative to the economy and we don't we
have a a family based chain migration
system that's got to end explain that so
a lot of our viewers tonight they hear
chain migration like what the heck are
you talking about she's gonna bring in
your old grandmother who's dying of
cancer from you know Mexico you
heartless horrible senator from Georgia
you don't care about the poor Mexican
grandmother dying of cancer that's what
they always say they go right to your
heartless and cruel well today we bring
in 1.1 million green card recipients a
year that's about twice our historical
average but that's not the real problem
the real problem is about 70,000 come in
that are skill based another 70,000 or
immediate family the rest are chained
that means that a recipient can name
their grandmother their cousin their
uncle or whatever and then that
recipient can name their grandmother and
uncle and cousin and so it goes on and
on and on and so after decades are doing
this we have now an immigration system
that does not fit the economic needs and
as we saw in this loophole it does not
protect our national security and what
is the difference assimilation which is
another issue I think that again people
are afraid to talk about this because
they're they're called you know all
these names or they're nativist as john
mccain said when you talk about like are
you assimilating or you creating many
pakistan's or many iran's or many
Somalia's in the united states where we
see this in st. paul in minnesota and we
see this in Michigan and Dearborn and in
Hamtramck Casey you see this in
different parts of in the boroughs of
New York again most of people are fine
people and they work hard but it's the
melting pot seems to just be melting you
know melting down it doesn't seem to be
a melting pot in some of these areas not
all but some of them but this is the
biggest difference since 1990 in the Ted
Kennedy idea and that is that if you
look at our historical immigration they
did that they came in they assimilated
in the communities they learned English
they developed a skill and they
contributed to the economy what we have
going today is this politically correct
we want to open border I mean that's
fundamentally what the
recives one isn't open they don't want
any border they don't want any they
don't want any deportation really except
maybe murders but other than that they
want no deportation they want everyone
can come and go and it's more of a
global order that's what they've always
wanted well and what we're trying to do
is add some reason by the way what we
want to do in a merit-based system and
eliminate chain migration is the same
conclusion the Democrats came to under
Braille Clinton President Bush
commissioned Jordan HW Commission a
commission to look at immigration
missions personally think of these
commissions every time I turn around
another commission they never get
anything done but here's what the
Democrats did they suggested a
merit-based system and Clinton
acknowledged that and supported that so
this is this should be a bipartisan
approach to this thing how many people
what's the percentage of immigrants in
the United States today who've come in
under a chain migration I read somewhere
it was a ridiculous high 13 million over
the last 25 years I'll give you the
number every year its 1.1 million and
only a hundred and forty is the the
worker and the immediate family you do
the math on that that's over nine
hundred nine hundred thousand people a
year are coming in in the chain
migration iteration it's a geometric
progression it really is exponential I
can absolutely are you confident that
the Democrats will limit chain migration
otherwise they're gonna kill the DREAM
Act they don't limit chain migration
they're gonna kill the DREAM Act will
they do it well we'll see I mean this is
where the the self-interest on the other
side we're gonna test that against
what's good for the country senator
thank you so much you it's great to see
you as always